what's up everybody I got a brand new
hour of material Raleigh North Carolina
I am there right now at good night's
comedy club I'm there tonight through
Saturday then November 2nd in uh
Pittsburgh November 3rd Detroit November
4th Columbus Ohio November 10th and 11
daa Beach Florida then we got New Haven
Connecticut Providence and Medford
followed by Phoenix Arizona Salt Lake
City and Denver and then we've added San
Diego LA and Reno Nevada Washington DC
and Nashville for the new year Christy
comedy.com for Ticky wikies let me tell
you something come see this material
because after I'm done with this tour I
will not be on the road for probably
close to a year so if you want to see me
Now's the Time to do it Christy
comedy.com get your tickets as a gift
get them for you we have a good time
this is the material I'm the most proud
of so come out see I'll kiss on the lips
real quick tour dates are on sale right
now at salvano comedy.com there's a big
Illinois run in November leading up to
my comedy special at the Vic in Chicago
on December 1st and 2nd the second sold
out as you guys I hopefully know uh and
so we added two shows on the first all
will be taped and all if you have a
ticket to any of those shows you'll be
eligible to win uh a flight hotel and
trip to the set of Impractical Jokers
I'm choosing one ticket out of those
four shows uh December 1st is still on
sale right now but it's going fast
savano comedy.com
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't hesit
to say hey babe hey bab hey bab hey bab
hey bab hey bab hey what's up
Babes we got Chrissy's uh moving today
and we got two of our great past guests
we got oh you haven't been on hey bab
yet no we got the two mics we got Mike
Cannon here and Mike feno sitting in
today uh they just he Mike Cannon had a
wild uh Vegas weekend so we were just
chatting about that my brain is is
recalibrating coming back to form oh man
I I I when was the last time you had had
one of those nights where the next day
you you couldn't get out of bed like
it's been from like from partying like
that I mean [__] a while I
mean like a New Year's Eve a couple
years ago probably where you know go to
m Madison Square Garden and take a ton
of acid and see Fish and then do you do
fish uh I've gone once and I went on J
uh January first one year I took uh
Molly and mushrooms and I turned into a
tree with my wife
who it was unbelievable she also feel
like she turned into a Tre the crazy
thing is is we're watching fish from
behind them which I love doing it was so
cool because it made me leave being like
whoever does their lights deserves a
Nobel Peace Prize he's
unbelievable unreal see this is how
funny as that he knows who does the
light well you want to know guess what
he now does all the lights for
everything at the Garden cuz fish does
the garden and you know so often and
they're like whatever you're doing
please do it for us and he just does the
Rangers games Nicks games so let me ask
you a question mhm you are you a fish
guy or with like you fell in your lap no
I went with no never hear I actually
went out of my way not to listen to them
understood okay so you how many times
have you seen them I mean
230 40 I thought you were about to tell
me 30 times and I was going to go 30
times no it's been yeah over over 200
times yeah wait but I don't know if I've
had sex that many times I don't I
definitely haven't I don't know if I've
done anything 200 except wake up I have
10,000 I'm the Malcolm Gladwell of uh
you're 200 what like 30 40 and who's
your Jedi how many today oh there's
people that have been like like
5600 that have yeah no totally how do
you do that in your life well so do you
not have a family do you have are you
are you do you have do you have a trust
fun like how do you do that well you
know I don't so you mean the 5600 people
Oran yeah I mean like and also I think
it was just a timing thing 235 is it was
but also there's like in high school and
in college like they would play like
three or four nights in an hour drive of
where I was going to school so it was
like literally I could see them like 40
times a year and it was like not a big
deal tickets were like 20 bucks they do
three nights in Worcester three nights
in Providence three nights in Albany
like and you're going to them all every
single show is different so and how
literally they never they never played
the same set list twice in their entire
whole career not but they played the
same song yes but they don't play the
same song they play the song the same
how many albums do they have a lot and
for however 14 13 14 albums and then for
the amount of albums they have they also
have songs that they only play Live this
is a whole thing dude I understand I
know I know it's like a cult but it's an
ecosystem and you going and this is why
I love not going with people who haven't
gone before because it's like you
watching episode 8 of season 9 of my
favorite show and I got to pause it and
go so this guy is this you know what I
mean and I'm like they didn't used to
play it like this and it's like this is
my dungeon that's going on all over the
arena every fish person like let me
explain something every other person is
like what the [__] is this so there's
like people that are loving it and
there's people that are like I don't
want to this is it's still going what
okay okay okay how many what's how many
okay what artist have you seen the most
and how many times was it just ballpark
because I had to think about that too um
in sync
twice I wasn't expecting either either
of those answers I wasn't expecting innc
and twice isn't that much if I'm being
honest I've seen Harry conik 10 times
I've seen the tribe cqu I've seen Beasty
Boys I've seen I've seen I mean I've
seen a lot of people like five 10 times
yeah but but but W wuang I probably seen
about 10 times yeah I may have seen them
three times okay but you know but you
know you know it's it's 1993 it's 30
years I know you know so I see them 10
times I see them every 3 years
right what happened
how do you how do you en enjoy seeing
the same people 300 times so they've
mastered the fear of missing out because
they don't play the so they played 13
shows at the Garden yeah in 2017 they
called it the Bakers Dozen they didn't
repeat one song and they sold all 13
shoes I think that's the one I went to
yeah so it's like do they sell a and
like they will play their like it's
almost kind of like collecting cards
each season where it's like you get all
of them and then you're missing that one
and you can't miss that show cuz they
play that one song and it's like [__] if
I didn't go I would have missed it
that's what and there's no album that
possibly has it on
it of course not mik of course I don't
have 100 tapes of that song in like how
much of what percentage of it is do you
still do hallucinogens at the shows yeah
okay so what percentage of the enjoyment
is that everyone not everyone okay good
great question no what percentage of
shows am I doing psychic no no what
percentage of the enjoyment is like is
tripping because I love tripping but I
saw dead and Co this year and it's my
second year in a row oh saw them twice
and then I I had a
great honestly that speaks a lot to you
you're my Gody but I had a great time
but I also was laughing because I'm not
like a huge fan I just have gone twice
and I was laughing that the mostly I'm
just doing drugs and public right so
right so what percentage is it of that I
a good percentage I was not doing give
me the percent of have you had 300 shows
High to not
high 7030 of what high not high wow and
what and a lot of times it was because
I'm going I'm do like four F four nights
in a row and I go way too hard the first
night and I'm like I'm going to die if I
do but what I would say is sober at a
show yeah it's like three beers and a
couple joints maybe you know what I mean
like I mean like not Molly not 100% High
then the answer you're not even one done
with nothing so how what percentage of
the crowd there do you think is high
it's got to be like um 130% because the
staff now is high why because contact
high they don't come and they don't come
and police this the so you're okay so
you're saying that the guarden makes a
concession yes that that 15,000 joints
are going to be lit and there's nothing
they could do about it and they'll still
have their 13 day even though it's
breaking all their rules yeah s ask ask
the people at the Garden who one their
favorite shows are they're gonna say
fish because nobody's fighting no one's
fighting nobody they're all we're buying
people [__] like I'm I'm on [__]
mushrooms and I'm like you want pretzels
or anything like for keeping us safe you
all you all are have the same exact goal
you all are there loving the the shared
experience is like probably no other
concert if I'm being honest right you
can't name another another person that I
mean maybe now Taylor Swift is coming in
in second somewhere like well and as an
outsider it feels like like a Meetup
Group because everybody's saying hello
to everybody even if they if they know
or don't know but people are like hey I
saw you last year like I saw them play
you know [__] you know why why do
they sound like
that what is that is that your drug is
what's the what's the male male male to
female ratio oh God so well it's gotten
better it's gotten better it used to be
all dudes it was just all Geeks yeah it
was all like your your first like your
first like it dudes anank Fest of jam
bams oh god there were dude fish has put
on so many festivals we went down to the
Everglades for the Millennium New Year's
Eve to a an a seminal Indian Reservation
it literally sounds like you're going to
the to the to the goddamn where's the
Pope live the vatic that going to you're
a Vatican they played from when the when
the ball dropped until when the sun came
up the next morning played completely
through the night no [__] and we just
were out there like are they high I mean
maybe then yeah sure for cuz that seems
like a lot of work uh-huh uh-huh to do
when SS a half hour it's not a lot of
songs but yeah well they four songs but
we would go I mean literally there were
years when it was like you know I mean I
remember doing like yeah like 30 or 40
shows a year it adds up quick Likes
music that much I never mind 30 to 40
the same show but then going to a show
where they play for 8 hours at a certain
point if I've seen them 270 times and
then I'm at an 8 Hour show a certain
point you don't go
time to go I'm good I've had it yeah
well I don't know have you ever to take
an extended break uh yeah yeah it's
funny they went you took a tolerance
break to Too Much up there I don't even
I don't even feel this anymore yes I've
only heard this song 300 times I'm like
somebody make me an insync mix cuz I got
to I got to cleanse the palet I got to
smell some the same people the whole
time I mean is it the same band that
they started with yes yeah four guys
that's the type of band where like if
one of them dies or something they're
they're not going to I know one song The
Bouncing Around The Room yeah and it's
like that's a you hate that yeah that's
like exactly why yeah cuz that's radio
like get out it they don't even play it
I bet they yeah if they do you hear a
couple don't they jump around on the on
the trampol theying another song
Gallagher no Then They smash watermelons
with their guitars um I love it because
it's kept me friends with friends that
would not have stayed friends with so
like my buddies from high school that I
went to shows with now we're in our 40s
and I still fish announces a tour and
then that text someone blows the dust
off that group text yeah I got it feels
like they're your Yankees or Nicks and
that's where you go and you watch games
and you catch up with your buddies and
and you don't talk to them again until
next season it's a thing okay uh okay so
my next question um is uh you know my
ADHD is kicking in but uh I don't like
sitting I used to to have to be front
row oh I got it I used to have to be
front row now I want to be behind the
stage I love watching Everybody watch
them aw it's so cool I also like I I
don't need explanations I like going
into things completely unknowledgeable
how did you find yourself there thought
it was interesting my wife's friends
were going they're huge fish heads and
she was like hey they're going do you
want to go and I was like I I jump at
the chance to do eny it because you were
I
like about the the music was great I
mean I like I personally for me dead
with John Mayor and him and Bob we and
the way they played guitar together they
mix with my musical sensibility a little
bit more but fish I mean truly dude they
play the trip like it's an instrument
they know people are hallucinating so
they Jam they slow it down in Meander
they guide you through a thing and you
get lost in it that's why like when I I
was standing with my wife and I became a
tree we became a tree it took us through
that so and in terms of so my feet
rooted into the ground taken mushrooms
three times two I had slightly like oh I
see it but you took enough that four a
public place which is a lot is that like
four chocolate bars full no no it's one
it's like one chocolate bar but full
full chocolate bar entire every square
and and so but I ate regular cuz
chocolate doesn't make me break through
anymore so I have to eat the the raw so
I don't like hallucinogenics the furn I
love go is mushrooms I only done it a
few times I felt in control I didn't do
too much I enjoyed looking around
because I was always like I'm here and I
understand I'm just getting this cool
little extra thing but if I were to turn
into a tree I wouldn't like that so so
what happens so how do you turn into a
tree and then and then when you're a
tree yeah are you like I know it's me I
just I have tree hands yeah I'm not so
it wasn't a disassociative at all and it
was more like I didn't look at myself
and see bark I just truly felt like my
body had extended into Roots I became a
trunk with my wife cuz we were holding
on to each other other and our arms
extended into branches and all that
stuff and it felt I'm I'm going to have
a panic attack just listening to that
I'm just going to have a panic attack
because I then is once you're there you
can't control it anymore right I mean I
I'm
I'm I'm good at hallucinogens I can
bring myself back you are like a black
belt yeah I I can do okay but like you
yeah I thought it was sap I was pissing
but but like later on my after the show
my wife and I were at a just have like
sitting down getting a drink to kind of
decompress and I uh she said she was
like man I like I had this whole visual
thing of becoming a tree and I was like
what the [__] and we found out later
that the two of us at the same time had
the exact same visual and were that
bluetoothed together wow so yeah yeah
try try try having that at a Taylor
Swift
concert I'm afraid that you get you get
like a migraine headache at that thing
what you talking screaming kids right
streaming girls oh T at Taylor Swift
screaming fans yeah yeah if I was a tree
at a Taylor Swifts I'd fall on some
people I would love to do mushrooms and
just be a problem at a Taylor S
show with a t like a tailor who shirt on
oh my god dude that that's I mean that's
tough that would give be a good
punishment for my show it would be oh my
God that is good um do you know what
type of tree you were or I don't
actually but it was it was Oak I assume
because it was it was large and uh you
you felt inside mhm that you were a tree
and your feet were per like so you
weren't scared it was welcoming and
interesting it yes really wel it was
never like I don't want to be a tree
anymore were you a tree until until it
wanted to be a tree or were you did you
stop being a tree when you wanted to
stop being a tree I stopped being a tree
when I stopped thinking about being a
tree okay so that's what happened so you
have the power I became a tree what it
really felt was it more of was
metaphorical than anything like truly
looking down down but like I felt
completely rooted and cemented into the
Earth I felt large I felt alive and I
felt one with my wife oh so those are
all amazing feelings so nothing about
that was negative or a tinge of like not
even no fear where Mikey was a tree if
if you had that experience you may have
become a skyscraper or like some big
like giant hulk thing where it's like
whatever your like powerful strength
thing is cuz I've had that like kind of
rooting into the Earth thing before
where I just thought like I had like
iron rods coming out of my heels that
were going like right to the core of the
and I'm like nothing can knock me down I
feel so strong and so powerful okay what
about guys thank you for joining what
about what about the other way guys
let's talk about vator uh both a website
and an app that you can use when you are
traveling and you are someplace and you
want a really cool experience something
from something you know that is very
common to something that's very Niche
they have literally they have 300,000
experiences spanning 190 countries and
they offer things from like simple tours
to Extreme Adventures um so you know it
takes the guesswork out of wondering
what you should do when you land in a
new city it's particularly good for me
because I'm on the road all the time and
when I have downtime I have to go seek
out and make sure I'm choosing like you
never want to squander the few hours you
have that day and and and and it's been
the case where I've booked something or
I've done something that wasn't worth it
so with the with Vador you can go online
you can look at all the experiences um
they describe them to a tea and then you
could look at the reviews of people who
took them so you could like book these
things with confidence uh prior to this
I had to go downstairs and sit with the
coner to do it I love it um I mean I in
Dublin I used it to take a tour of the
cliffs which I really like you'd have to
go get a magazine and flip through it
this thing I'm literally coming from the
airport on my app already booking what
I'm going to do on the trip so it's
really cool um there's always
flexibility and support uh there's free
cancellation uh there's payment options
and 247 service so download the Vador
app now and use code Viator 10 for 10%
off of your first booking in the app in
the app one app over 300,000 travel
experiences you'll remember do more with
vator this show is sponsored by better
help no surprise there guys okay um
listen if you are a therapy veteran if
you've never tried it uh I think a good
way to start or a good way to continue
uh is with better help it's online
therapy completely online okay it's
designed to be convenient and flexible
for your schedule it's super super
simple you log on you fill out a
questionnaire quickly and they match you
with a licensed therapist and that's it
you could switch therapists at any time
no additional charge um you know know I
use therapy all the time because I think
it's really important to flush out what
I'm thinking um a lot of times I'm so
busy that I hold these thoughts in my
head and I don't process them and I
don't get them out and you would be
surprised how much just speaking for an
hour about what's on your mind on a
regular basis how far that goes so if
you're someone who you know is just an
overthinker or H has a lot on your plate
or just wants to feel maybe like get in
touch with yourself a little bit more
I've done it it's worked for me uh try
it out um let's see here get a break
from your thoughts you know with better
help visit better
help.com hey bab today to get 10% off
your first month so that's betterhelp
hp.com heyab okay thank you for
sponsoring uh the show better help talk
me through something that you didn't
want to be a bad trip so any bad trip
that I've ever had has actually been a
positive experience because it's forced
me to front feelings that I've
suppressed so it's hard in the moment
and I've white knuckled my way through
it but I've also faced some of my
greatest life trauma and greatest fear
and stuff head on and I think it's made
me a better person we have to wow that's
heavy so so that's what you're taught
when you do it a lot it's like don't run
from things run towards them like if
you're having a bad trip you got to go
head on to the thing and go like I'm not
afraid of you anymore and all right you
hear me I'm not afraid of you anymore sh
that
[__] so so so so so when you're when
you're hitting it head on uh if you're
not like alone or at like a like a relax
thing if you're at a concert or a party
and then it comes at that do you have to
go find a place to be alone or someone
just jumping around you like you know
dancing and you're dancing but you're
like oh my God I'm I'm thinking of this
so I I like sitting I literally wrote in
my phone during a mushroom trip there is
nothing on Earth I like more than
sitting and it was just a realization I
had about myself so I sit at the concert
I really was having a tough time through
the dead and Co concert the first hour
and I was like facing some shitty
thoughts about myself how do you go head
on with that though because I'm working
about this iny in my regular life
because I want to confront them because
I don't want because they they deserve
it they deserve it for many reasons one
because if you just keep pushing
something away you know it's it's you're
not going to process it it's not going
to you know it's going to manifest
itself in negative ways and you have to
get have closure right so but sometimes
it's so traumatic or so bad that you
also there's never a good time for that
and you don't want to think about it
sometimes you don't want to let it creep
in but then sometimes I feel guilty that
I don't give it its due if I push it
away too much now this is something I'm
talking about in regular life now if I'm
at a party and the thing that I don't
want to confront in my regular life that
I push away because it's just too heavy
how are you processing that while people
are like literally playing like you know
like like you know you know what I mean
like I I just don't understand that and
so you're sitting in this chair and
everyone around you is doing whatever
and you're like thinking of like almost
like the Rock Bottom moments of oh for
sure yeah and just I I have a lot of
real uh self-talk problems and I'm
really mean to myself and that was what
I was doing the entire first hour of
show lar David in episode of curb when
he's screaming in the mirror himself
exactly that ex sh that exact thing and
then so this was incredible right it's
their first show after the pandemic it
was the first show or first show that I
had been to and my son was born to Hey
Jude which was like a really beautiful
Moment We we played both my wife and I
were listening to it during the
C-section so it was like intense whole
intense thing they never really play
covers all that often I'm white
knuckling trying to make it through it
out of nowhere they start playing Hey
Jude way and I just dead in Co and I
just shoot rainbows out of my f
fingertips eyeballs dick Hool chest
everything and start immediately
hysterical crying
[__] give my wife a huge hug we're
singing along to it and from that moment
on it was the most euphoric beautiful
concert I've ever been to yeah you fac
this your stuff headon like that too
well yeah I've been doing uh yes I've
done a bunch of large doses of mushrooms
just me and a guide like me and a and a
person that sits there with me to make
sure that like uh I don't like go jump
in a river or some [__] but it's
well yeah and I just sit and do like
large doses of mushrooms and do that and
that's been what the I just remembered
you have to give me that we talked about
in the car ride on the road ketamine
yeah yeah did you hear about this I've
been doing I forgot I thought it was
mushrooms but yeah well no I've done now
um I watched somebody do a set on
ketamine next skankfest oh yeah wow it
was awesome was it advertised as such no
okay back to that a surprise appearance
by kadam wow yeah I couldn't imagine so
wait so let me
yet get there so you how do you face
head on these things I had are you go
there are you do you have a start
wailing and crying at a party no nothing
like that I I'm if I need a break I'll
step outside but for the most part I can
I I'm Irish I can I can I can really
weather a bad storm and a straight face
this is where I'd feel incredible doing
it with Mike because I'm Italian and I
get emotional at at any so when I'm
doing it alone I did it to do the work
like I decided I I'm awful to myself I
had a horrible year of depression and
whatever and I'm like I got to dive in
and stay down there until I [__]
figure it out so I went in and did like
a couple of large doses like four three
and a half to four grams of like golden
teacher and I sat in this room the The
Who names
[Laughter]
thisam that's what that is and that's
what that is yes 100% I I want to be the
guy who names it I I sat with this I sat
with this this woman and I'm like I lay
down in this bed that she made like this
big like bean bag bed and I go I feel so
so comfortable because normally my wife
and my dog are always laying on me and
she goes that's cuz you make them feel
safe and just that one notion I felt
like sloth and Goonies when chunk like
you're going to live with me now I was
like like my and I just start this isine
or mushrooms mushrooms and I just start
sobbing uncontrollably and I I feel like
I cried years and years and years of
like self hatred all out at once and I
just came out of it like I mean dude I
had a headache from crying but it's like
the front of your head is open for like
the next like three weeks or so you have
that expansion of just like things it's
a residual I had a notion I had a for I
had a notion that and everyone's going
to think I'm nuts but whatever I have a
feeling that the only two things in life
that are real are love and fear and if
you operate from Fear you're not open to
the love that's around you but if you
operate from love fear doesn't stand a
chance this was a thing that I realized
on mushrooms in it like oh I get it now
like I'm either looking at things from
love or fear but then but then that is
realized and then when you're not high
anymore you can you hold that it's been
years and I still think about it almost
every day and to me that imprinted on my
head where I'm like I either look at
things me personally I'm either afraid
or I'm comfortable but does this not
mean that something chemically is
happening that's altering you
permanently yeah that's the
point but then that's also but then why
doesn't it happen in Reverse or does it
it does take that with you bet like I
know people unfortunate see I'm I'm a
huge advocate of mushrooms but I've also
seen it work in the opposite way where
it's triggered somebody's suppressed
mental illness and it made them bipolar
or not made them but it certainly you
know kind of reinvigorated some dormant
trait don't necessarily get what you
want because you're really rolling the
dice then the second time I went and did
a large one I had a really bad time and
it was like I never achieved lift off
like I was kind of like stuck in limbo
and every time I closed my eyes I felt
like I saw like you know those like
parade dragons like those kind of like
the ones that look almost like brick
breaker you know coming at me and every
time I closed my eyes I saw them so I'd
open my eyes but my eyes wouldn't stay
open I was just having this like and I
turned to her and I'm like I'm having a
really bad time right now and she's like
let's just we'll get through it together
you're fine I'm looking at you and
you're fine you ate mushrooms they're
going to wear off and they did and I
confronted these things and once I
realized I was coming at it from Fear I
was like just and they just dissol they
literally just disintegrated and I
didn't have them anymore so prior to
that you were definitely afraid of
parade dragons or I
watched I think just Chinese
people I did watch what do the parade
dragons
represent Kurt Russell showed up I was
like what the hell Big Trouble in Little
China yeah I don't know and then that
but I never thought about those in my
entire life you know what I mean but
it's like you confront these things that
you that that were a thousand pound
weights around your neck your whole life
and you go oh I'm not afraid of you
anymore and you just move on that thing
that's been [__] with you forever
doesn't matter anymore and it's
literally like they call it like your
default mode Network like you have a a
record that plays in your head right and
it's the same story over and over that
we tell ourselves and then when
literally when you do these
it you flip the record and you hear a
whole different track and it's not
you're not playing on that same yeah I
mean that's with the K I'm like I'm on
like what 35 or 40 now ketamine sessions
with my doctor and it's like I sit in a
leather recliner they put an IV huh in a
row 35 in a row 35 sessions yeah but
it's like the first four weeks you go
twice a week okay and then you go like
once every couple weeks and then you go
remember I I got in touch with you about
to I wanted you to come film me doing it
once which is so weird cuz I started
filming ads for ketamine therapy you're
kidding me yeah my doctor's like I don't
think I want cameras in here but anyway
yeah so that's a thing where it's like
that's how you find out you're being
molested like how come my wallet's
lighter every time I leave here but that
one's totally different that's like
you're literally sitting in a recliner
with like the glasses and the the
headphones and it's like what do you
mean the the glasses like well the the
the the eye shade things like you wear
like the sleep mask that you would wear
like you don't have to but you can you
know and it helps you just kind of like
you zone out talking oh I'm sorry I'm
talking into the IC tea that's another
uh side effect of uh what do you want
now a little bit of both why why does it
say you can't eat or drink eight hours
before because it causes nausea if
you're prone to it so but it's not it's
not a big deal it's the best thing in
the world I swear to God it's like
literally
like that's interesting create playlist
so you're listening to music there have
been times where I've listened to music
sometimes I just listen to like sounds
like a you know like deep in the woods
kind of whatever like type stuff I don't
listen to words stuff with you know like
Native American FL okay I thought you
meant like you just listen hard for
stuff in the woods outside just like
picturing pooya with the Avatar
people in full blue face you guys you
guys you went full blue you guys have uh
positive negative mushroom experience I
just did a bunch of mushrooms in
Amsterdam I love it those must have been
fantastic what's what's your craziest
like Hall like your craziest moment that
or funnest or best know most interesting
I don't know it doesn't impact me like
hallucinating okay no I just enjoy it
you you you don't get visuals a little
bit do you smoke weed with it yeah yeah
does that enhance it or distract for me
personally like when I smoke I mean weed
and mushrooms go together like chocolate
and peanut butter it is like a perfect
the best combination ever only you mean
like you mean like chocolate and
caramel no you said peanut butter right
is this that
show it's a new experience he just said
chocolate and caramel is a better
combination than chocolate and peanut
butter and I had to oh yeah no way but
please please continue Ian but so for me
like I'll I'll roll a
couple I'll roll a couple blunts before
because I've tried to do it while on and
it is it is impossible blunts blunts
opposed to joints yeah because tell the
audence what a blunt is as opposed to a
joint I uh I'm from the I'm from the
suburbs of New York so we smoked blunts
we would put five on a blunt each of us
yeah uh Dutch I'm a Dutch Master guy
have been forevs and uh so what happens
you buy a Dutch Master cigar which is a
cheap cigar slice that open right yeah
or unwrap it you can do it either way I
follow the Tupac method I crack it down
the middle God bless they just found his
killer my mom texted me about it that's
right yeah I got a text for my mom at
1:00 in the morning day they just said
they found Tupac's killer did she spell
it right let me look what did she did
did it's also hilarious it's like yeah I
found them too he was talking about it
on the
internet I I honestly wasn't keyed in
there amazing I was like but I had
already read it before she sent it it
was so funny I've never spoken to my mom
about Tupac in my life and I've never
heard her I didn't know she knew who
Tupac was and uh let's
see okay this is what she said this is a
series of texts I got after after
midnight okay uh I came off the stage
she said I'm glad that you had a good
show
um now skip that okay then she writes on
TV now in Sync release new music first
time in 23 years you heard right you
heard that was at 11:55 followed up by a
1213 text also Tupac's killer was found
wow what would I'd be your best friends
with your mom we have the same music
taste I'm asleep I'm asleep she's up at
at at at 1: 152 I wake up and I see my
mom texting me and I'm laughing and I
just say I never talk to her about it
and I only write her back who was it cuz
I want to see what she says you know
what I mean and then she responds at
5:09 a.m. oh Jesus the best I don't
know I didn't watch the whole thing
which means that she was was interesting
enough already to text me about it she
was like and we found Tupac kill and she
was like you know what I and then she
texted me so excited to text you she
doesn't even pay attention I was so
excited to see what she was going to say
cuz I read it and it was like this guy
that was in this gang and he fought he
jumped his his his nephew and I thought
she was going to write that whole thing
and she was like I don't know I also
love that your mom sleeps like two and a
half hours a night yeah she sleeps like
a goddamn Navy
SEAL like on a mission you know it's
like just 2hour increments amazing
she just takes gathering information and
sleeping gather information and sleep
gather teex nap gather teex nap that's
it but uh I interrupted you you were
saying hello fresh baby you get Farm
Fresh GRE portion ingredients and
seasonal rep recipes deliver right to
your doorstep skip trips to the grocery
store and count on hella freshh to make
home cooking easy fun and affordable
that's why it's America's number one
meal kit you guys know how much I love
this product I use it Jazz uses it we
cook it s uses it it's really all we do
we get the because the pre-portion
ingredients that's what is the best part
about this is all the guest work that
goes into cooking eliminated it's just
healthy meals right to your door you
cook them you get the family involved I
love it this is not my family bonds the
most wonderful time of year is also the
most delicious every single bite of the
holiday season with hellofresh you can
get from over you can choose from over
45 weekly recipes and over a 100 curator
picks from the hellofresh market right
now go to hellofresh.com
free and use the code hey bab free for
free breakfast for Life what come on
hellofresh.com heyab free and use the
code heyab free for free breakfast for
Life One breakfast item per box while
subscription is active that's free
breakfast for life at hellofresh.com
heapfree with code heyab free I
literally don't know why you wouldn't
sign up immediately you're getting free
breakfast for Life go get that bacon in
your mouth game
time game time uh we love the game time
app we use the game time app you got to
go to
gametime.com
gametime.co it's last minute tickets at
the best prices guaranteed lot of good
features views from your seats best
price guarantee you get uh easy to find
tickets for every kind of event in your
area they literally do the lowest price
guarantee and they prove it with that
because with the game time guarantee it
means you will always get the best price
if you find tickets in the same section
and row for Less game time will credit
you
110% of the difference that's absolutely
right uh it is and this flash deal is
like last minute deals and this is
something I didn't see but the Zone
deals is where you pick the section game
time picks the SE and that's going to be
an average of 20% savings every time I
love it take the guest work out of take
the guest work out of buy tickets man
and they got every sport football
basketball baseball concerts comedy
theater and more yes R find tickets for
us use the game time app if you can't if
we're sold out find the tickets for us
um right now all you have to do is
download the game time app create an
account and use the code hey babe for
$20 off your first purchase terms apply
again create an account redeem the code
h y b a be for $20 off download game
time today last minute tickets lowest
price
guaranteed blunts oh blunts yeah so for
for me I think it's like a little bit of
the tobacco and and weed that helps
bring out the visuals so there's a
there's tobacco in a blunt well it's
it's the r yeah so in the leaf is
tobacco yeah so I'm not I'm not I can't
doit traditionally I don't love them no
because I feel like the blunts could get
me a little nauseous maybe it's just
something that I need to get over I'm
like that with Backwoods but I used to
smoke cigarettes I quit like 10 years
ago and because I think this is probably
my way of cheating a little bit and
getting a little bit of tobacco n or
whatever into my system I am I feel that
way though with like Backwoods which is
like the real Hood blunt that's what you
know and I every time I smoke that my
head [__] swims it's like the cartoon
when their head becomes a fish tank and
they're just like that's exactly how I
feel like when you swallow dip as a kid
yes that same watch do that at sh did
Constitution's getting weaker I already
have a weak one but like I I'm getting
nauseous hearing you describe it no
kidding yeah nausea is not you you have
a very I have a thing with thing with
nausea but I get nauseous easily easily
I get motion sickness in a car even so
it's something that has plagued me since
I'm a child and so when you talk about
nausea I get that like sense memory
about nausea and I start to feel nausea
you know what I found find interesting
about you in particular we were in a
tour bus once you and me and we were we
had a long drive and someone ate fish in
the tour bus and it didn't bother you
and I was getting nauseous was it fishy
it was nasty fishy it was like hot fishy
where I was getting like freaked out and
I was going to tell you cuz I didn't
want to be the can we pull over and
throw this out but there was like a game
Fish Funk like hot garbage water in the
summer let's make him puke mik
you dude those are real tears the words
gave me fish Funk don't good oh it was a
gamey fish Funk it was it was gross yeah
just just just think of that I'm telling
you I could you can make me throw up I'm
not trying to I know but you
will if you keep talking I'm not even
dude I would love and hate to see
that I have to stop thinking about it
because I'll throw up
and I had didn't have a problem with
it you say you say I didn't have a
problem you did not have a problem with
it then know in the moment it's almost
that's where I almost think it's like
you thinking about it it's worse than
you experiencing it cuz I'm like I was
hating it and I'm like how the [__] are
you not freaking out right now you guys
are not like that with anything oh I'm
bad I my my old factory up here is very
I smells make me sick smells Mak me so
sick fi and I went to Area 15 the first
night of skankfest and we it's like this
psychedelic kind of entire Art Exhibit
but it's immersive and it's supposed to
be very cool it was a little try Hardy
to be honest like all that [__] all that
like Galactic psychedelic stuff I can
just lay in a field and look at the
stars and it happens I don't need it to
be in my face and all that stuff I try
too hard just play techno and blare [__]
in your face and it's like I'm freaking
out
man it's like let me do the heavy
lifting just just just kind of like give
me some stuff to look at like don't
forget to stop by the gift shop pick
yourself up exactly so somebody threw up
during the at the on the main floor and
this and I had a stomach ache from the
mushrooms as it was so it's like Stand
By Me after that dude everywhere I
puking at the and somebody some employee
was overspraying F Breeze around it and
all over the place the mix of everything
and I I was just suffering for 3 hours I
why not leave because I was trying to be
a good friend to feni who really wanted
to be there do you remember in Grammar
School some I know I'm so self-pleasing
or I'm I'm so like a people pleasing ass
even while I'm crashing my ego I'm like
whatever I'll do whatever for my
friends did you clue him into how bad it
was so why didn't he do this for you
he's a
sociopath pure sociopath straight vom
them out remember when we puked in and
puked in gram school and they came out
and put [__] wood chips on saw dust
yeah and they just let it sit until it
soaked and then they sweeped it up but
it smelled the whole time like the bile
inside and you're supposed to like like
the
mile I thought you meant the mile run no
no no no class would s and then you're
supposed to then you're supposed to
still retain information that she's
talking about cuz people [__] pissed and
throw up in in high school I mean in
grammar school more often have you ever
thrown up on a student like on a friend
I have I did too Michael del I apologize
bro fourth grade this B I appear I so
sorry yeah really D fourth grade I was
like I don't feel so yeah and I just V
all over his shoulder and back exorcism
vomit too like little kids are like I'll
never forget I'll never forget this
because I've never seen the look in the
eyes of someone that was so horrified in
my life did did he look at you did you
see his face when you did it yeah
because I got a look of like it was
almost like horror and disgust that you
see in a movie like a so disgusted and
so horri in the eyes he was
like like literally like literally and
I've never seen someone do that for real
and I've never seen it again and it's
tattooed I felt so bad he was wearing a
white onwhite
sweatsuit he was so excited to wear that
and let me let me paint the picture for
you and I think I might have told the
story already so I apologize but app
propo we were freshman in high school
and we went on our first ever school
trip and it was a ski trip up to like
Hunter Mountain or whatever the hell it
was yeah yeah and it was on we had to
arrive at be there at the school at 5:
a.m. to depart I went to an old Catholic
boy school but we did it in tandem with
another girl school and it was allowed
open to all the students so we're
Freshman School year starts in September
this is December so oo with three months
into a school year okay I don't really
know no about it yet it's filled with
mostly seniors I forget what year it was
it might have been 1990 91 the year the
Giants went like 10 and0 11 and0 12 and0
whatever that 90 I yeah their first
Super Bowl and
I I don't like getting up that early I
didn't eat and I get car sick you know
so we're on this thing it's intimidating
as hell me and baaz he's at the window
we're toward the front I'm going say I
would say I win the first four rows and
everybody's up and walking around
there's older girls and there's guy big
guys already like that have been like
you know men they've been men already
for long time to and and you know you
just don't even want you don't even want
them to like get you don't even want to
cause any you don't want them to even
turn not that they were being mean but
like I don't know what's going to happen
like I don't want to be like hey look at
everybody that's what I don't want you
just want to be invisible never did I
think that the worst possible thing for
that would happen to me on this trip and
I was getting really really nauseous
okay there was a bathroom in the back
okay but every single all right so I'm
getting nauseous and I don't know what
to do and I feel like I might get sick
and you know when the pro the launch
sequence has been already activated and
now what you're doing is everything in
your power to suppress the fact that
your body is like soon you're going to
throw up you get a little back of the
mouth moisture something PR I that right
so so there was a kid behind me his name
was
Nino and I remember he had a bandana in
his hair and he was cool and he but he
was new but apparently he knew other
people anyway he says you're nauseous he
goes yeah he goes dude I have a bagel
with cream cheese maybe you need to eat
something and he gives me half of his
Bagel or his bagel and I take it and I
thought it was going to help and I bit
into it and something about the cream
cheese which I love by the way nothing
against the cream cheese but something
about it just activated it even more and
now it was happening in double time and
I had to have twice as much willpower
and I look to my friend I go I'm going
to be sick I don't know what to do this
is happening I'm going to be sick he's
like get to the bed
so I get up but every single girl and
Senior guy was standing talking flirting
and it you're talking a bus that holds
60 70 kids and there's 30 people in the
bus aisle and I'm and I'm you know
freshman and I'm like excuse me and I
don't even want to talk loud excuse me
but the whole time I'm getting more
nauseous I'm getting more nauseous
excuse me excuse me and then all of a
sudden I get like 30% of the way and I
look and I go I'm not getting there yeah
and I know I'm throwing up what do I do
I don't want to throw up in the middle
of them so I start to run back to my my
seat maybe I could Crouch which is home
base at this point that's the only place
I know it's the least worst place to
throw up although it's no
[Music]
prize I get I I excuse me excuse me
excuse me and now I can't even talk now
I'm like can I hold it in my mouth and
get it into some type of
receptacle uh I think maybe there was a
brown paper bag that he gave me with the
with the you know the thing so I get I'm
turning I get to my seat that's like
giving you a basketball net to throw
into never that wasn't manufactured for
these purposes you know all anyway it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter I never
made it to the bag so I was I turned
into my seat and I went and I I went to
throw up
standing I covered my mouth and it shot
out in every direction because I put up
basically like a screen in front of my
mouth like you put your thumb on the it
shot out mostly forward but in five
different
streams and every one of them went
directly at him and on him he was in a
white sweatsuit he recoiled in horror
and he
went and I just watched as it came out
in three waves he was covered in puke
from head to
to not a lot of people saw it again
people are up talking The Backs it to us
we're in the front right and so I he go
he goes oh and then I didn't know what
to say and I sat down I go I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry and I forget what's
happening there it's like it's the wake
of it right and we're in the wake of it
I'm sure he's like oh oh and I was just
like I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry and
he doesn't know what to do and he's so
then they smell the puke so someone on
the bus goes yo somebody threw up right
and then everyone's turn around like who
threw up who threw up and I'm like oh my
God oh my God and someone turns around
and sees it on bazot baz they call him
baze and they go yo it was this kid and
then they blame
baz that he threw up on himself oh my
God and then I don't even think I don't
even think like he said anything cuz we
were so timid and we were so like
shocked and I just think that everyone
on the bus then thought that he threw up
on himself and then he was so
embarrassed he didn't go back there to
get it off and so we drove to like Bay
Mountain this was like early this was
like in the first 20% of the drive oh no
and then it was like 2 and a half hours
of not only him sitting in my puke but
me sitting next to him smelling it and
then everyone thinking it was him oh wow
dude that's awesome so I have thrown up
on
somebody oh my God the kid I puked on
just look sad like it looked like it
confirmed everything he's ever thought
about himself get pissed on by not your
choice oh no yeah I got pissed on yeah
that was another that was another big
to-do like Stiffler off the roof or
something like somebody accidentally I
got wait like all right I I could talk
about it yeah I'm I'm past it
now it stayed with me for quite some
time so I was in my young 20s and I went
to Atlantic City for um just the night
we used to go and drive back believe it
or not that's wild and uh we used to to
go to the the club right and
so this was in like the early 2000s
there was a small window of time where I
dabbled with ecstasy okay Fant we go to
this club it's called Deja Vu it's an
Atlantic City it's open it's known to be
open to like it might even have even
been the after party M I forget but like
open at four and stayed open something
like that St I don't know what it was no
we went somewhere after that it wasn't
the but it stayed so we're there and I'm
with like probably like 10 friends and
do you want to make do you want to just
keep you have somewhere to go no I have
nowhere to go you going to stay for the
next one anyway you going you want to
just like I'm driving home after this
you want just want to just double it up
I'm down Okay so we're in the middle of
list cuz this is uh cuz we're we're a
little bit in but we'll cut this episode
into two so we're on two weeks so why
don't you guys give plugs in this one
and then I'll continue this story at the
top of the next episode beautiful what
do you think a piss Cliffhanger I love
it yeah this is going to be a it's a
this is going to be a golden shower
Cliffhanger what you have Bo you had a
golden what a a golden teacher this okay
so this was your golden
[Laughter]
teacher October 20th I'm going to be in
Angeles at the Hollywood improv lab so
that seats about 11 please come out uh
October 21st I'm in Burbank California
at Flappers come out to that then uh
levat toown in November DC in December
at Mike Canon comedy.com and uh I have
Chris's plugs also for uh yes of course
he said uh he's got Chris also wanted to
let you know he will be having a
full-loaded cocktober of dates
California Nebraska Missouri Indiana and
North Carolina are all getting stuffed
with his standup check it all out at
Christ DC comedy.com he wrote I read
directly from the copy copy all right
baby um my special don't let me down is
out on 800 pound gorilla 800p gm.com pay
what you want it'll be free November 9th
on YouTube nice so YouTube Mike phoa m i
k f i n o i a uh October 19 2021 I'll be
at DC Improv and all my other dates at
Mike pho.com thank you hilar ious
hilarious comedian just want to cosign I
saw what the special looked like also
cuz candy directed it and uh man I can't
wait to watch it you're [__] awesome
I love you you're hilarious that's so
and I will just say for good measure um
the first time I ever saw you is the
first time I ever saw Chris live about
10 years ago it's the first time he
headlined Carolines yeah yeah was that
with Carly 10 plus years ago he she was
not there okay okay but he I think he
was with her right or no actually they
had just broken up cuz he talked about
it on stage got how he went to Atlantic
City cried and drank penino I remember
that and our show went up in flames and
you featured for him and I remember
being like holy [__] I swear to God no
reason for me to say it you were so
funny thank you dude and it was that's
10 years ago featuring and I just was
like wow like so fun thank you very much
I mean it's so mutual it's not even
funny thank you babe thank you thank you
I might as well throw a couple dates in
on this instead of um it's October 25th
this is coming out so uh if you're in
Mount Pleasant Michigan soaring Casino
for two shows on the 27th that's with
the guys it's our first group uh thing
in about four or five months uh we're
not going back on the road together
until what I believe is January uh for
me my remaining dates here are all in
November November 9th Peoria November
10th Rockford November 11th Cedar Rapids
12th Springfield Illinois and then we
got the 16th is duth Minnesota the 17th
is Appleton the 18th is rockchester
Minnesota and uh the 19th is uh
Davenport Iowa and then the 29th is the
Elkart Elkart Indiana have you heard of
that no the learner theater in Elkart
and that's it and uh up until the
special taping which is at the Vic
Theater in Chicago four shows on
December 1st and 2nd as of right now
there's some December 1st uh tickets
left and if you didn't know if you have
a ticket to any one of those four shows
it doesn't matter where you're sitting
I'm choosing one person from the four
shows to fly to New York I'm going to
put you up in a hotel and bring you on
the set of Impractical Jokers just a
thank you to you guys for selling it out
so fast for me so savano county.com
appreciate you guys that's awesome dude
yeah don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate say hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey Bab